the Joe Rogan experience do you remember
when they had that 11 year old drag
queen oh the Desmond is amazing yeah
yeah yeah and they were making this big
deal about it yeah and he's going to
drag clubs and dancing around they put
in the news like it was some this what
uh what a great thing
what a great thing we live in his truth
he's so brave he imagine if there was a
12 year old that was just sworn to be a
ho
like I am oh ho I'm just gonna wear
fishnets right and high heels and I'm
gonna stick my ass out and I'm a dance
powder around with a lot of makeup on
how different is that well he's also on
the spectrum I think I'm 99% sure so the
and this photos him videos with naked
drag queens violet chachki and it's just
like look this is something for well if
there's like a little boy who's being a
Chippendales you know what I mean it's
like how is this appropriate for kids
and and it's on Good Morning America
it's different they're a bunch lady
scream when they're trying to get that
dick well I mean that would be the
equivalent right cuz he's performing a
gay clubs and they're cheering a mom
that's a place where guide go to hook up
with guys well here's the question - do
you think guys have hooked up with him
no oh God hope not oh let's go you want
to talk about this because this is a
rabbit hole that I've been on recently
oh boy you know kids getting [ __ ]
Robert yeah because I had a friend in
October who sat me down and he's like
look I was raped as a kid for a long
time and he only realized cuz of this
show because he was watching when Jake
the snake was on the show oh my my
friend Matt and everything Jake was
saying he's like holy [ __ ] this is me
and this really [ __ ] him up for a
while and as he's talking to me and he
goes I can't even be mad because it was
another older kid and I know he was
getting it worse than me oh and the
thing that's really [ __ ] up is he
didn't know how I was gonna react right
so used to be mommy's sleepy no mommy
was a drunk right and until Betty Ford
the first lady came out as an alcoholic
now people like you someone says oh my
mom was an alcoholic here like oh that
sucks but you don't think anything of
him right if someone's if daddy had a
temper no daddy was abusive but we know
what to do with that information and
when I started talking about this on
Twitter and elsewhere that this
is really common and because all of us
do not think of kids in this way we
don't want to think about it's so sick
they're the ones who have to deal with
this nightmare and it's really really
everyone I've talked to know someone hmm
and I just told another friend when he's
like oh yeah my sister I just found out
was being molested by her grant our
grandfather their whole life and then
it's like she's the one who's acting out
and we're yelling at her for acting out
so Joey I need one of the things I
wanted to talk about is this is
something that has to change these
people can't be the ones who have to
worry that if they tell me or your
friend that we're gonna look at them
like oh you're free gotta know what to
do with this you know because they're
the ones who are suffering for a very
long time and I think that keeps people
from speaking out because that fear of
being labeled I did they'd almost rather
keep it to themselves and not of other
people know that they've been molested
you they don't want to for you to be
uncomfortable around them right and
there was a girl in my high school
she told another girl that her brother
been raping her for years and she went
to mom and mom says you know you're
talking about that can't happen but this
happens all the time and we don't have
the space to discuss it so I've just
been kind of talking about this a lot
more and encouraging people to talk
about this a lot more because it's
they're really really a lot of people
who are suffering because of this and
what do you do here's the big question
something like that what do you do to
help the person who's been molested and
what you do what do you do to the person
who molest someone well the the person
who did it I I can't even begin I don't
know but I think what happens is just
like with gay rights right the more
people who come out and talk about it
the more easy it is for someone to call
someone else and be like this happened
to me you know what I'm going through
let's have this conversation have you
seen this very strange trend that's rare
but common enough and actually predicted
where people are talking about people
that are pedophiles that it's some sort
of a sexual inclination that we should
have yeah
sympathy for them because it's not-it's
nothing they asked for and it's no
different than being born gay or being
you it is just a thing where you're born
in a way that is there any science to
back that up at all
I perfectly happy to believe that people
can be born with this inclination I
don't care if I've involved an
inclination that I want to murder people
well I better figure out how to deal
with this yeah you not I mean right and
I think that's a complete in many ways
red herring if it's something that they
can't change that doesn't that makes it
worse that that means you can't have no
reason to even dangerous yeah right your
cannibal that can only mean right
vampire living amongst us right because
instead of stealing Souls you're
stealing someone's future and and the
thing about these types is they're very
common they're like any predator you're
gonna be drawn to where the resources
are so they're going to be
disproportionate in those fields where
you are interacting with your targets
right so that's what makes it so sick
it's not like you have these ideas okay
fine you can have whatever ideas you
want you were slaying does that ground
work you know to prey on these kids and
you know what you're doing it's it's and
again I don't know what to do with this
information but I do know that this is
really really bad and you know people
talk about this is the truest form of
being a victim there is and the sickest
part about it to me is how many of these
kids go on to molest other kids yeah
it's it's like like a disease like
they've got a disease i well I told Matt
that he should there's two ways right
they go on I told Matt you should
consider reaching out to this guy and
telling him you forgive him because he's
like because it's possible that you're
like 10 or 11 you're doing this you grow
up and you realize what you've done and
what this means and I don't know how you
could live with yourself it's well we
have to hope and assume that it ended
with that that he didn't continue doing
it as they get older and write with the
same age child yeah it's it's and what's
even worse what happens when it's within
the family right this happens I talked
to someone who's a former sheriff in the
when I was in the Midwest and you know
this was his job to helping these kids
he goes it is so much more prevalent
than you think and what happens is
families you know how back in the day
you don't want to talk with divorce
because it's shameful I didn't
understand what they were ashamed of
whatever and now it's like oh that's
just crazy uncle Nick keeping away from
the kids it's like
that's not a thing that is the uncle
Nick yeah there's too many of us already
yeah the thing is like even saying that
there's too many of us we should kill
pedophiles like that's it's if you put
that up like in a real intimate
situation you're talking just a bunch of
people that really cared about each
other and were good friends like I think
we should kill pedophiles they be like
[ __ ] yeah but most people would say yes
but in public in public discourse like
saying should kill pedophiles like okay
but here's a problem sometimes people
get accused to be in pedophiles and
they're not like you remember that
school that uh there was a daycare
school and these kids were actually
being coached into saying oh yeah you
little kids it was a famous case and
that eventually the case all fell apart
but not before these people's
reputations were ruined everything was
ruined their business was shattered all
because these kids had made stuff up and
then other people had like coached him
into making more stuff up and then
everything got crazier and crazy
what was the name of that it was it was
a very famous case I mean they made a
documentary about it because it shows
almost like there's a mass hysteria that
can go on especially when you're talking
about something that's particularly
heinous right like the abduction and or
the rape of children rather because
we're all so scared of that being real
that we'll pay attention as much as
possible so they have these news stories
they have all these different things
that are attached to this and then
people keep probing and they keep you
asking questions and then it accelerates
and grows because it's a focal point of
attention but people start lying but
we're also so scared so we don't want to
think it could be true
and we don't want to thank either one
right true right someone would molest
kids or the kids would be coached in the
lawyer but I most of them are horrible
I'm much more concerned with people who
are dealing with this and how they can
get yes of course no of course I think
that I'm saying that's why you can't
kill them oh yeah I'm not advocating
killing anybody I'm just advocating for
people and I don't I'm not a victim of
this I just have a friend and again
everyone I've talked to know someone one
degree of separation oh yeah
and I'm just saying for the people who
had gone through this just like Matt
listening to the show III this what I
told him I when I thought my experience
when people come to you in a vulnerable
way don't tell them what you do you
think they want to hear be as vulnerable
in return so I said to him I don't
Matt I don't care I don't think of you
any differently I don't think you're
damaged I don't think you're a freak I
think it's awful I can't relate to this
at all I know you're glad I can't relate
to this at all and I think it's great
that you want me to kind of talk about
this to stop someone from blowing their
brains out
[Applause]